far cry 6 is a game about revolution
home brew weapons
pet alligators hobbled together
tentacles and
super moves yeah far cry 6 is very much
a far cry game and it seems to be
leaning even more heavily into the
series dangerous but
tongue-in-cheek mechanics in this video
we're going to go over
everything we've learned so far from
ubisoft about this game e3
2021 is right around the corner and
gamespot will have a ton to show during
our play for all events so make sure to
give us a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel
so you don't miss out let's get to it
one thing hammered home in our preview
of far cry 6 was that the loadout of
your character will matter
and picking the right tools is important
weapons are highly customizable and gear
comes with specialized perks
loadouts can accommodate a number of
playstyles meaning that you can now
holster your weapon and try not to draw
attention you can sneak around
you can pay bribes to different enemies
hijack trucks and commit sabotage you
could also just play it like a standard
shooter
there are 49 weapons with plenty of
attachments and while we didn't see any
kind of stat space weapon rarity like in
far cry new dawn
we did see a range of categories when it
comes to arms juan cortes is your weapon
supplier
on the island of er he's basically cue
from james
the two bond together like fire and fury
through him or in the world you can get
different weapons across the regular
resolver and supremos category regular
weapons seem to be leftover guns from
last century's cold war like the sks
fal and m16 but also there's everyday
items like baseball bats throwing knives
make their return as a stealth go-to
weapon
next door resolve their weapons which
are hand-built improvised items
these range from mildly plausible like
the flamethrower
silent nail gun and emp grenades to the
ludicrous
like a minigun built from motorcycle
parts and a vinyl record launcher that
plays macarena
you've seen this stuff in far cry before
but this game is taking that over the
top and improvised aspect
a bit further there are also some very
silly improvised mechanics like
healing through pressing a lit cigar to
your wound above resolve air weapons we
have the sopremos that means far cry now
has super moves in the form of an
upgradeable backpack we are now headed
into
just cause territory
some of the supremos demonstrated in our
preview was a backpack mortar launcher
that could clear an area and also a
rocket jump this all ties into far cry
6's rpg
light gear system which includes perks
clothing can do things like improve your
headshot damage
increase stealth and mobility or
guarantee throwing knives hit their
target we're not sure yet if that means
enemies will have a corresponding gear
or difficulty level like they did in far
cry new dawn where players needed to
keep up with their weapon levels to do
proper damage
in that game players didn't have to
worry about their clothing and armor
though we did ask about how much of new
dawn systems would come over to far cry
6 in an interview but we didn't get a
specific answer
although not referred to in this
presentation as fangs for hire
there are pets in this game including
guapo the alligator that can chomp your
enemies
and chorizo who is very cute and
distracting to let you commit
silent murders
so that's guns and gear let's talk about
transportation inspired by the isolation
of cuba the island of yara is stuck in
time which means modern technology is
kind of rare
many of the guns and vehicles you'll
find are repurposed from old stuff
there's a wide range of transportation
like horses and aging cars but from
there players can build up mad max style
technicals with all kinds of weapons and
attachments bolted on
you can also hijack a tank regarding
flying things
the game seems like it's going to
attempt to keep you grounded for a while
with flat cannons scattered around the
island
this is kind of nice as much as we like
flying helicopters it's always kind of
broken far cry games by letting you go
from objective to objective without
really engaging in the world
it's possible you'll be able to blow
these up quickly and do it anyway but
we're hoping flying's more of a late
game thing
alright so who are you you play as danny
rojas who can be either male or female
unlike most other far cry games dany is
fully voiced and will appear in
cutscenes
they live on the island of yara which is
being ravaged by a brutal dictator named
anton castillo
played by actor gene carlo esposito the
island's been isolated for about 50
years leading to some urban decay
his goal is to return yard to its former
glory with the help of
about 300 000 soldiers and a bit of
martial law his son diego seems like an
unwilling participant but we'll have to
see how that pans out
if you remember you played the role of a
son in a similar situation in far cry 4
and wound up potentially being just as
bad as your old pops
dany is a military dropout and their
family was part of the regime previously
so their story might be echoed in diego
to fight the good fight you're working
with a local revolutionary leader clara
garcia and her army of guerilla rebels
so what does that mean from a gameplay
perspective you'll find a lot of the
usual activities like taking checkpoints
and outposts plus stomping around the
jungle on trails in search of hidden
loot but you'll also be in the
huge capital city with its skyscrapers
in underground areas and that kind of
urban scale is new to the series
on a side note we also saw some mini
games like playing dominoes
seems like a nice way to unwind overall
the presentation didn't answer all of
our questions like if far cry 6 will
continue the more heavy-handed rpg
systems of new dawn which were a bit
divisive with fans
we can't wait to get our hands on the
game and really put that weapon
customization to the test
despite the heavy political setting that
centers around a malevolent dictator far
cry 6 does not seem to be taking its
moment to moment gameplay too seriously
there will be more to say about this
game soon as e3 kicks off this june
so be sure to subscribe to gamespot's
youtube page and we'll keep you up to
date
thanks for watching
[Music]
do
[Music]
you